if you want to figure out your purpose
you need to figure out what you stand
for as a human I brought a whole book on
it it's here it's called your one word
it's about finding your most important
core value who are you when you
understand what you're seeing the most
important core value is everything else
becomes so much easier so for me it's
belief I believe is my single most
important core value how does that help
well with every decision that I make
it's seen through the lens of belief
every video content that I make is about
belief it has to be every interaction I
have every Workshop every book every
meeting all of it has to be run through
the belief if I'm hiring somebody onto
my team skills alone aren't enough it's
great that you can write copies do you
believe an entrepreneur so when you
understand your core value everything
else becomes clearer and you're less
likely to follow what other people want
you to do everybody around you they have
a goal for you even if it's well
intentioned they have opinions on what
you should do with your life everybody
around you this is what you should do
with your life everybody has an opinion
you don't know which way to go if you
don't know which way to go it's because
you don't know what you stand for
because you're standing on quicksand but
when you understand your one word you're
who your most important core value it's
like you're standing on a rock that
nobody can push you from me motivation
watch your top 10 with believe Nation
hey this is Nina Wayne Carmichael and
chances are you are the most ambitious
person
no you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan Carmichael
and his top 10 rules for success I hope
you enjoy because I'm going to enjoy
so how do you figure that out quickly
right I mean this is 200 something Pages
let's boil it down super quick for you
you want to think about all the people
that you love your favorite teacher what
you loved about your parents think about
your favorite musician your favorite
band your favorite song your favorite
movie your favorite book all your
favorite things the thing that when you
are around consuming it reading it being
with them it makes you feel bold alive
amazing confident Unstoppable right
we've all had those moments it's just
not consistent enough yet we're gonna
make it for you it's just not consistent
enough yet and so write down a list of
five to ten things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love that you love like you
could get lost spending time with them
or reading them or listening to them
then write down three keywords that
describe each of them
so your favorite teacher why did you
love Mr Jones it's not because he taught
you grade four math right there was
something else about Mr Jones that you
love why do I love Seabiscuit the movie
because it's about an oversized jockey
and an undersized horse and an owner
that has no money and all of these
things and they all come together it's
believe right my parents taught me that
I'm Evan can surely Karma because I can
do anything that I believe that I can
right and so through all the things that
I love believe is the common thread what
is it for you you have to figure it out
you have to figure it out it doesn't
have to take you years of work just
write down all of the people and the
things that you love three keywords for
each like do this this is important just
do it today it'll make a huge difference
in your life it's worth it this is the
best 15 minutes you can spend in your
life do it pause the video and do it and
then just see what comes up consistently
what word comes up over and over and
over and over and over and over again
chances are that's your one word that's
your who then when you discover it you
have to start living that life
so you know if my one word is believed
then I gotta think okay who around me is
not belief what am I doing that is not
believe what projects am I working on
that are not believe and it gives you
Clarity and forces some tough decisions
and the more unhappy you are right now
in your life for business is because you
are out of alignment with your one word
if I was doing something that was
anti-belief if it even have made tons of
money I'm not going to be happy because
it's against who I am it's against my
core value same thing for you if you are
unhappy
because you're doing things that don't
align well with your core value and you
don't know what your core value is so
fix it rule number two act on your ideas
most people never manifest their ideas
because you don't trust your ideas that
bold idea that came to you that made
sense to you in the moment the next day
feels too bold too crazy too insane too
not for someone like you I believe that
the decisions that come to you when
you're feeling bold are actually the
right ones for you and you have to take
immediate action on because otherwise
your head gets in the way and talks you
down from doing the things that you
should be doing so right now I'm in the
process of looking for a creative
director for my business someone to look
at all my content suggest ways to make
it better to to be focused on The
Branding and opportunities for me and
this was a suggestion for Mark Drager a
friend of the channel a long time
personal friend of mine as well he
helped film my very first video he's the
reason why I did top 10 moves to success
long story with Mark and he said every
when you need a creative director for
your business creative director or brand
manager or CEO somebody to be in charge
of all the creative decisions and
getting me out on the stages that they
need to be out on so how do we make
these videos better that's that person's
role and so in my head
when he first said it I'm a little
afraid I'm scared like
how do I find this person I need to Vibe
well with them I don't I can't just
bring anybody into that role I'm a
pretty weird duck and so this has to be
a good you know long-term fit for me how
much is this person going to cost how do
I fit into my cost structure right now
with my business how are we going to
deal with conflicts it's all of the
negativity all of the things that
are reasons why it's not going to work
and so in setting to focus on this is a
bold idea and I need to at least explore
and I need to try I need to play it out
maybe it works maybe it doesn't but
teaching yourself teaching myself that I
do both things I do scary things I do
difficult things and being scared is not
a good enough reason for not to take
action and so those ideas that come to
you trust that they came to you for a
reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel both like man I
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do is just start
going off and doing that
because what's going to happen is you're
going to plan plan plan plan you're
going to spend all your best energies
just stuck in planning mode instead of
actually going out and taking action
you're going to tell your friends about
it they're going to tell you it's a
stupid idea you're going to sleep on it
you're going to wake up and tell
yourself it's a stupid idea and then
what happens is no momentum the biggest
thing that is missing
smiling sits next to me filming that's
all that's missing you're a genius you
have great ideas great genius Amazing
Ideas you're just missing momentum
because once you get the idea you sit on
it and then you tell yourself why you
can't do it instead of going off and
proving to yourself that you can rule
number three put in the effort
self-love comes from doing things that
you think are beyond your comfort zone
that you're not capable of doing and
just getting up and trying to do it
that's when you love yourself when
something is easy and you win you
actually don't feel that great about
yourself if you were to go and run a
race against three-year-olds and you won
great yeah you won you might even post
about it on Instagram but you don't love
yourself you don't feel good about
yourself because you played small
because it was easy because you were
expected to win because it's inside your
comfort zone when you play inside your
comfort zone always you don't love
yourself it comes from doing difficult
things that's how you build respect
that's how you build credibility it's
how you build self-love for you forget
about how other people respect and look
at you it's how you feel about yourself
that's the game and that comes from
doing difficult things so if you ran a
race against three-year-olds and you won
great who cares you don't feel great
about yourself because you were expected
to win but if you ran a race against
Usain Bolt
and he ran backwards on one leg he would
still probably destroy you
but you should feel great about yourself
because you did the thing when it was
hard to do the thing
you might have lost to Usain Bolt but
you got in the race against him
that's how you build self-love when you
tie your self-respect when you tie your
self-worth when you tie yourself love to
the effort that you put in on a daily
basis that's when you start to win when
you tie yourself love to winning to
getting results you lose
when you tie your self-love to how many
likes you have on Instagram reviews or
subscribers on YouTube you lose it's
about the effort are you putting in the
effort every day because if you are
proud of your effort on a daily basis I
promise you you are going to crush it
but if you are only proud of yourself
when you win here's what's going to
happen you're only going to take on
small things you're going to play small
your entire life because you're only
going to take on projects that you have
a pretty high chance of winning at
because that's how you have love for
yourself and that's a losing game
because you're capable of more you're
capable of doing a lot more stuff you
keep a little playing a bigger game
you're capable of having a bigger impact
you have to it's your duty
it's your duty to love yourself
when you love yourself you'll be able to
spread that more and help other people
and so how do you love yourself it comes
from doing difficult things it comes
from when your heart's beating like
crazy and you're scared and it's some
big project and you say I'm gonna try
I'm going to try to do that scary thing
I'm going to try to record a video in
public people may be watching you
doesn't mean your video has to be great
chances are gonna suck
but you tried and you should feel great
about yourself rule number four take
control of your life saying I never have
the time is the single greatest excuse
that is preventing you from
accomplishing your goals you are not
allowed to say it anymore stop it stop
believing your own lies whatever story
you're telling yourself as to why you
can't do it how much time you don't have
somebody else who made it had it way
worse than you did they made it and had
it way worse than you did if they can
make it you can do the only difference
is the story you're telling yourself
that you don't have enough time to do it
so I'm going to give you a more fun
example on this one uh I want to get to
being a better League of Legends player
okay I would play League of Legends
I don't know once or twice a week
depending on what was happening in my
calendar I started sponsoring A League
of Legends player my first Esports
Venture this guy named Kyle menko and he
plays Teemo team was a character in the
game I play Teemo he's the best Teemo in
the world in any region around the world
he is the number one guy and I said Kyle
menko I want to sponsor you and part of
the deal is you're going to coach me I
want you to coach me on how to get
better
I want to get better I want a climb I
was in bronze which is the second worst
division in League of Legends I said
what was the best you've ever done said
silver which is the third worst division
League of Legends and so he said okay I
can help you how often are you
practicing I said I don't know once or
twice a week it's like okay that's not
enough
I need you to play three games a day
three games a day
and a game takes 35 to 40 minutes
sometimes longer depending on how long
it takes to get into the game could be
45 minutes maybe even up to an hour I'm
thinking my head three games a day are
you nuts I don't have time to do this I
can't make that happen I got all these
other responsibilities
it's important you got to stop telling
yourself that you can't do it how do I
justify playing three games a day when I
have all these other stuff I need to do
I need to run a business I want to scale
I want to grow my YouTube channel I want
to grow my impact I need to write my
book I need to launch my YouTube course
I need to spend time with my wife and my
family I got lots of other things I need
to do I need to sleep you have all of it
how do I justify spending three games a
day to improve my Teemo
I don't have the time
your actions map to your Ambitions I'll
look at my calendar I made a way
I'm gonna do it I want to get better I
want to improve now I don't do it when
I'm traveling so I'm here in LA right
now so I haven't played my three games
since I've been away but when I'm in
Toronto
pretty much every day that I'm in
Toronto I'll get my three games in and
I've gotten better the results speak I
went from bronze to Silver and now I'm
climbing up through silver and I'm
hopefully the goal is to get the gold by
the end of the year so that was the
fourth worth fourth worst Division and
you're starting to get
once you get in the goal then you get a
little bit higher now you're starting to
get some kind of not reputation but
significance and just like you're
actually a semi-decent player right so
I'm I'm chasing down my League of
Legends goals because your personal
goals you may be watching and thinking
well what is like why are you wasting
your time doing it's a personal goal to
me
it might be a waste of time to you maybe
building a deck for your backyard is a
big waste of time for me maybe making
your own clothes or whatever other hobby
you have cooking or crafting is a big
waste of time for me right so don't
judge somebody else's personal goals
this is a personal goal of mine I want
to chase it down and I want to not tell
myself that I don't have the time right
as soon as you hear yourself say I don't
have the time you're not taking control
of your calendar you're not taking
control of your life of course you have
the time you choose not to prioritize it
that's that's the change in language you
need to make you're not allowed to say
I don't have the time
instead I choose not to prioritize it
because now you're in charge now you
have nobody to blame because when it's
somebody else's fault when you have the
time that's not your fault
somebody else's fault that's everybody
else who has demands on your time right
you can't do anything about it so let's
just stay here I never accomplish your
goals
choose not to prioritize it
once you take accountability once you
take responsibility to say I'm going to
take control of what I want to do in my
life that's when everything starts to
change also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there you look at the people who've made
big money they've been they've been
chasing something that they love doing
because otherwise you won't put it in a
fork if you're just chasing an
opportunity you're probably not going to
make it if you don't love it enough
the people who love it will crush you
like if salsa dancing was the hot trend
for 2020 you could say great I'm going
to make tons of money salsa dancing
being a being an instructor and then
I'll do that for three years and then
retire and go travel the world and do
what I love you'll never make the money
salsa dancing because Alex is going to
destroy you
sorry yeah because he loves it right
because you'll you'll be uh
a wannabe and you'll never put in enough
work to actually get great at the thing
like if you're if you're going to work
with somebody who's going to be in your
in your production
and they're just you just want to make
it as an actor because they think it's a
path to make tons of money because Brad
Pitt makes 40 million a movie or
whatever it is
but they don't actually care about being
a good actor
they're not going to get into your show
like you're going to spot that out and
say no I need people who actually care
about the craft rule number six learn
how to sell you don't have to be an
extrovert to sell you also don't have to
be a slime ball to sell either all you
need to sell is a vision that you
believe in and a passion to make it come
true and if you don't learn to
effectively sell that genius idea that
you have in here that can serve the
world will never come to fruition and
you'll never get the impact that you're
after so I'm here in LA and over the
past two days I've been on the podcast
for Jordan Belfort Wolf of Wall Street
and Jay Abraham who's the legendary
marketing Guru for Tony Robbins and
Damon John and a whole bunch of other
people and I'm on their podcast I'm
telling them that they need to be on
YouTube that they need to get their
message out I want to see them more
heavily invested I want to see their
message reach the world and
five years ago
Evan five years ago would have been too
afraid to humbled too worried that I
might not be perfect that I wouldn't be
able to persuade them to do the thing
and so I wouldn't have tried
and I still have a bit of that in me
when when Jordan Belfort asked me how
good are you like how good at YouTube
are you and the answer that I gave was
within the thought leadership world if
you you want to help entrepreneurs I'm
I'm top three five in the world
even as I said it feels weird saying it
because the the Canadian or Carmichael
kind of humbleness is pumping in but
it's also true
because when you're talking to somebody
who is not super familiar with what
you're doing they're trying to get an
understanding when I'm talking to Jordan
Belfort and trying to give them an
understanding of what I do and why my
message is so important for him I'm
trying to serve him I'm trying to help
him I want him to win
so The credibility is important backs it
up and me not strongly believing in
myself means that he won't believe in me
either and one of my favorite messages
from Jordan and I told him this at the
beginning of the podcast interview was
sales
is about a transfer of certainty of all
the things I've learned from Jordan
Belfort that is the number one thing
that still Rings true in my head sales
if you want to sell people you want to
persuade them on something again not for
nefarious reasons not to screw somebody
over not just to get their money you
want to persuade them I'm here try to
persuade Jordan trying to persuade Jay
try to persuade lots of other people to
take their message and put it up on
YouTube to spread it to the world it's
for them right I got frustrated with
Jordan halfway through the interview and
he said why are you frustrated because
he's making it a joke and some and
having fun and he loves having fun on
the show and and it's a more
entertaining show he's way more funny
and entertaining than I am I told him
you're doing this for the audience
because people watch the show I'm doing
this for you like we're here at a
limited time and I want you to win I
want to get this out of my head into
here so you can go take action on it
right
so the ability to sell and persuade is
based off your ability to transfer
certainty
and so when you fully believe in the
thing when you fully believe in a thing
like this is right this is a thing that
has to happen in service in service for
your customer in service for your
audience you have to do this not for me
but because it's the best thing for you
when you fully believe it then you have
to go all in on it rule number seven
don't settle for average you have
Michael Jordan level Talent at something
but instead of being world class at that
thing you settle for being just above
average at something that you should not
be doing Albert Einstein once said
everybody is a genius but if you judge a
fish by its ability to climb a tree it
will believe its whole life that it is
stupid that's most people's problems you
are a fish
and you're trying to climb a tree
instead of going and being great at
swimming this is the exact problem that
I'm on a mission to solve so I recently
had a young entrepreneur come to one of
my Toronto q a meetups that are free
that I host every week and he said Evan
I have a problem I'm trying to decide
between what my parents want me to be
which is an architect and what I feel uh
yearning towards which is being a
musician and I don't know what to do
I know how to decide I don't know how
I'm going to be a success as a musician
I don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and this is clearly the fine
path for how to do it and he's afraid
I think that's so many people there's a
safe perfect path that has been designed
that people have done forever and ever
and ever and ever and ever or this is
new crazy messy
unrealistic unsafe unsure path which is
following your passion being an
entrepreneur and trying to figure out
where you're supposed to go
here's the thing if you only go down
that safe path if you only take that job
if you only listen to your parents or
other people and you do what they want
you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you that you could have
done that you didn't take action on and
you hate it it's never been easier to
actually be yourself and build a
business and have success being uniquely
you right this was not open to your
parents and definitely not your
grandparents the ability to be an
entrepreneur on the side making money
using your phone is something that your
grandparents don't understand it's just
it's totally wild and so you are a
unique individual right you are I am we
all are you have unique interests
personality traits belief systems you're
unique you need to do something unique
if you are unique you need to do
something unique if you're stuck doing
the same thing that somebody else wants
you to do you're never going to be happy
now there may be some alignment you may
not absolutely hate the job that you're
at but you know you're capable of more
you're Michael Jordan you are the
Michael Jordan of something you're a
genius and absolute bona fide genius at
something this is why I think it's the
world's greatest problem this is why I
do what I do every single day in making
this content videos for you because I
want to unlock people hope hopefully
more than one at a time but even if it's
just one person who watches this video
and gets unlocked I'm pumped because I
think if everybody is off doing the
thing that they are a genius at man I
want to live in that world rule number
eight take more action hope without
action leads to pain and suffering
watching videos like this is not enough
it might give you hope but hope that is
not tied to action and you doing
something will mean you never accomplish
your goals the answer is always action
and when that doesn't work out more
action and when that doesn't work out
more action so a couple years ago I was
in New York and I was meeting with my
agents in one of them
said what am I trying to do what's
what's my vision what's my mission what
I'm trying to accomplish and I said I
wanted to spread belief I wanted to
spread hope and he jumped all over me
about the Hope like you want to spread
hope Hope's not enough you can't just do
hope and and I remember walking away
he's like what's he talking I hope it's
so important if you don't have hope how
are you going to believe in yourself to
go chase something down without hope you
got nothing right without hope and
belief you got nothing
where I realized the difference in the
thinking is the usage of the word is
people hope things will happen it's not
having hope in something it's hoping
that it's going to happen and then they
sit on their bed and sit on their couch
sit at home and do nothing
that kind of hope that's not a strategy
hope and belief is your first step it's
your first entry point in you have hope
that things will happen but then you
gotta get up and do something right and
so
figuring out that message when I was
talking to my agent didn't come to you
right away in the moment because at the
same time as much as I'm filled with
hope and belief in humanity and what we
can all do I'm work right I'm taking
action I'm making three to four videos
every day we haven't had a day in the
past five years where a video hasn't
gone up every single day I don't know
what that consecutive streak is but it's
long it's big
I'm working my face off every day in the
achievement of my mission but I also
love hope and belief it's why I have
this channel so I have my other channels
is I want I want to be around people
who've done a lot more I want to learn
from the great so I'm going to learn
from people who know more than me and
when I see that it gives me hope that
it's possible
it gives me belief that it's possible
that if they can do it I can do it too
but you still have to do it the ability
to do it versus actually executing and
doing it are two very different things
right the difference Gap is going to be
the action and so yes I want you to have
hope I think it's important but it's not
the only thing you got to make sure you
turn that hope and not just rely on a
strategy but you're doing the daily work
to chase down your dreams rule number
nine try new things people aren't lazy
they just don't have dreams that Inspire
them they default to thinking I'm a lazy
person I don't have Ambitions I don't
know what I want to do in life I'm just
I'm just a loser no you just don't have
a dream that makes you want to go off
and do something and until you figure
that out you're going to be in this
constant cycle of feeling like a loser
it's one of the most common questions
that I get asked on my Ig streams I go
live every single day on Instagram at
least right now while I'm on my tour and
every single day I get asked some
variation of Evan I'm lazy how do I get
out of it Evan I'm procrastinating how
do I get out of it one you don't call
yourself a lazy person there's no such
thing as a lazy person if you are
procrastinating or you're being lazy
right you are being lazy doesn't mean
that you are a lazy person there's two
reasons why you're doing it there's two
reasons why you are being lazy one
you don't have a dream that's big enough
you don't have something that inspires
you you don't want to get out of bed in
the morning if I was an accountant I
would be a really lazy accountant I
would hate my life not to knock
accountants it's just not for me if I
was a video editor I would be I would be
lazy I would hate my life I don't want
to be a video editor I don't want to be
an accountant actually there's most
things in the world that I don't want to
be and if you've forced me to do that I
would be lazy that's 95 of America I
think 95 of America wakes up and drives
to the job that they hate and then
they're lazy there
but they have dreams they have Ambitions
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something you just have to find it and
so if you don't know what that thing is
then it's your duty to go off and
explore you test you try you see
you say yes to a lot of stuff like this
is the most important thing that you
need to figure out in your life if you
don't know what your dream is you have
to go off and try things
just like you won't get married until
you go on dates you won't get married to
an idea until you go on dates until you
try it until you say yes
and the acid test is did I like it do I
want to go back this is fill me up did I
enjoy the process of it can I see myself
doing this and having fun because when
you're having fun doing the work
that's when it will fill you up
that's when you won't be lazy and there
has been times in all your lives where
you felt that where you felt the joy the
energy the ambition the drive and so you
need to capture that and say yes and
find what it is that your big dream is
and rule number 10
can you go to the next question I don't
know no this is a good question
are you seriously gonna skip this that's
a great question no I had a great answer
to admissions you tell me afterwards how
often do you take stock of your life and
evaluate the direction you're going
when you do okay next question I don't
like this one too
because it's too long right is there any
security zoning there it was not if you
can't answer the question in 10 words
he's out okay
where's someone you never want to travel
to and why that's
it
well I didn't even hear what you said
where is somewhere you'd never want to
travel to and why I went on to travel
everywhere
it can be even like something small like
a sewer
[Laughter]
a tree would you want to travel to a
sewer no
or something similar I don't know what
else how about a slaughterhouse
no what but where would there be a
slaughterhouse I don't know General like
you could pick you don't have to pick
like China or something you think you
could pick us no I'm saying you don't
have to pick something you pick you'd
have to be a city or a country it could
be something anywhere it does it's
thrilled
my [ __ ] I don't like to go oh there you
go like a horror Horror amusement park
or something yeah yeah okay that's
that's a good one that's a good one good
answer good answer good answer Nina good
answer good answer
I would say space why well don't you
want to go I would like to go to space I
don't just go into space what if I say
hey everyone I go to space and I want
you to come by wow
you want to go to space yeah why not why
not it's not it's cool I mean you get to
control you get to control what like
you're in the space you know you move
you could you know
it makes no sense you use the control
you get to move what you just want to
float yeah swim no I don't want I don't
like swimming
your purpose comes from your pain the
thing that you struggled the most with
as a human being is what you want to
help other people through for the rest
of your life something terrible happened
to you you know at some point in our
lives something terrible happened to me
happened to you nobody gets through this
life trauma free something terrible
happened to you and that terrible thing
will Define you in one of two ways
either that was negative and in that
story haunts you and holds you back and
and fills you with all these limited
beliefs or
you recognize that that thing that
happened to you is The Ultimate Gift in
that your purpose now becomes to help
other people not struggle the same way
that you did when you can transform that
giant pain that you had emotional pain
when you felt the most worthless as a
human being into something powerful and
positive because it's now not just about
you anymore it's about serving and
helping others who are like you
that's when everything changes my
purpose is to help entrepreneurs believe
in themselves more because the the worst
day of my life the worst moments in my
life for when I was in my first business
and I quit on my business partner and I
I had no belief I
I was down on myself I felt worthless I
felt I was working every day and just
nothing was working out and what do I do
what do I do and I I quit I'm my
business partner I quit because it was
just too much too much work too much
stress too much negative thoughts too
much just lack of self-worth not enough
belief
and I woke up the next day and I and I
still I went back to work because I did
not want to live with the regret and I
actually had a voice of Oprah in my head
telling me just find a different way to
stand
you know if it's not working out it's
okay don't quit just find a different
way to stand and I eventually made it
through
we we built a company sold it that had
other successes but
the thing that fills me up forever is
helping other entrepreneurs who are
trying to believe in themselves because
that's back to who I was
and I still make the content for 19 year
old Evan because there are millions of
people out there right now who currently
are 19 year old Evan
and so
one of the most helpful things you can
do
is try to figure out a couple things one
what was that most painful moment like
how do we turn this into
practical a lot of entrepreneurs a lot
of you watching this channel you are
positive you are energetic you are
enthusiastic you are pouring into other
people you're probably the most
optimistic person most dream filled
person in your circle and that's amazing
and that's a gift and you should keep
doing that and
you still have lots of moments where you
don't believe in yourself when you don't
have the courage that you need you don't
have the boldness that you need and and
we don't like looking backwards you
don't like look into the painful moments
the entrepreneurs ambitious positive
people it's like I don't want to think
about all the negative things that
happen to me I want to go off and build
this thing I want to say stocking
negativity is that you can you relate
but it's important to think about that
most painful moment not to sit there and
live there and say oh whoa is me but to
recognize
that there are millions of people right
now who currently are still struggling
with that thing that thing that you have
overcome even if you're not done growing
learning and proven yet that thing that
you struggled with that you're coming
through many many many many many many
millions of people right now today are
struggling with that thing
and they need you they need your hope
they need your voice they need your
message you need your inspiration you
can reach those people in a way that
Evan Carmichael can't that Oprah Winfrey
can't that other people can't because
you experienced it
and I and Oprah have it
so step number one is to think about
what is that most painful moment
that you struggled through
that you wouldn't wish on anybody else
step number two then becomes well how
did you get out of it again you're not
done climbing but you're way better off
than you used to be it's funny how we
we criticize ourselves for not being
further ahead like I I should be up here
her followed that idea I'd be over here
by now all these other people are doing
all these amazing things and I'm still
feeling like I'm stuck okay
but also look at how far you've come
right you know you want to keep climbing
growing swimming Etc but you've come a
long way compared to who you used to be
and every now and then we need to pause
for Pat ourselves on the shoulders say
you know what I'm I'm way further ahead
Than I Used to Be
do you from five years ago or ten years
ago we look at the you today and say
holy cow I can't believe you've done
that
right Evan from 10 years ago who had I
don't know a thousand subscribers on his
YouTube channel would look to Evan now
and say oh my gosh that's crazy I can't
believe you did that even though right
now I'm thinking I gotta do more I gotta
be better gotta work harder gotta gotta
go faster gotta come with new ideas I'm
not pushing enough right if you look
back man there's been some tremendous
growth you've grown a lot
and so how did you how did you get out
of the hole that you were in how did you
stop struggling as much you probably
tried a million different things but
there's one or two or three things that
worked that's teachable
that's teachable to other people the
thing that saved me was modeling success
I looked at Bill Gates's story and I
modeled that for myself and my software
company then started to have success so
what have I taught for the past 20 plus
years now is how can other people model
success so how did you get out of the
hole that you were in
and then how can you then teach that to
other people
because they're struggling because all
of the tests and tries and attempts and
failures that you went through to find
the one two three things that worked you
can Now shortcut somebody else's path
this is what I think it means to max out
your Humanity this is what I what I
think it means to live in what Jonathan
Fields calls maximum sustainable
generosity it's like how can you keep
giving in a sustainable way
that fills you up because you don't want
to just do things for you humans are
built to serve it's wired inside you you
want to feel like you matter like today
matters like the work you're going to do
today is going to be meaningful to
somebody
and the people you love help the most
are the ones who are currently
struggling with the thing that you
struggled with
so figure out what that thing is that
most painful moment in your life that
you never want to go back to
and then how did you get out of the hole
now that is teachable
and then set number three is having a
courage to share your story
I get it it's scary it's difficult it's
hard to put yourself out there to share
what you went through the struggles you
may be afraid of how you're going to be
judged or seen you know today you were
just a normal person and now tomorrow
you're going to put this out there now
now maybe you're you're scarred or
you're tarnished
but it's important because
by you staying silent it perpetuates the
Silence by you being afraid to share
your story everybody else who's
struggling with the same thing that
you're struggling with they feel afraid
too they feel like they don't belong
they feel like they're weird and not
accepted and not normal
by you putting out your story and what
you went through and are still going
through
it gives the permission to other people
to feel like they have somewhere that
they belong that they are normal that
they're going to be okay too that
they're not alone
so you share in your story I used to
really struggle with thinking well only
egotistical Maniacs share their story
and talk about themselves right it's
about serving well hold on
by you sharing your story is actually
serving you're not sharing your story
just to have the spotlight on you just
to say how amazing you are you're
sharing your story because you're hoping
that other people can see themselves in
you because your purpose comes from your
pain you're trying to reach the people
who currently are who you used to be
and in looking at you and hearing you
what you've come through and where you
are now that will serve as inspiration
for them to keep going
or for them to even get started or for
them to not take their life today
because they saw your video or they read
your book or they saw the post you put
on social media
sharing your story is not about you
sharing your stories about impacting
others and they can see themselves in
you where they can't see themselves in
Evan Carmichael or Oprah Winfrey or
insert you know whatever expert Guru or
entrepreneur
you have to figure out what that most
painful moment in your life was
you have to understand how you got out
of the hole because it's teachable and
then you have to share your story
you put the message out there
because your story will change
somebody's life ultimately your purpose
comes from your pain
you want to serve you want to help you
want to feel like today matters you want
to feel like when you show up to do the
thing that you're gonna do today it's
going to have an impact maybe not on
millions of people's lives
but on at least one person's life if you
felt like today you were gonna touch in
a deeply meaningful profound way at
least one person's life
you're gonna show up totally differently
than if you felt like today doesn't
matter that nobody cares
and just forget about the day
I love you I want to see you win
let's make it happen when you figure out
what you stand for everything becomes so
much easier
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs who
they're doing this and they're doing
that and they're doing this and then
also this thing and it's
feels like it's all over the place right
have you ever felt that you're doing so
many things and it feels like it's all
over the place and you don't know how to
bring it together it doesn't feel like
it fits together nobody understands what
you're doing either
the way to bring it together
is to figure out your most important
core value
if you actually did the exercise and
I've talked about this in in both my
books built to serve your one word
if you actually did the exercise you
think about what do I stand for if you
have to pick something right now your
single most important core value what
would you pick mine is belief what's
yours it is all sorts of exercise we get
into and how to actually do it if you're
struggling with that but just pick pick
something it's not going to be so far
off
whatever comes to mind right now pick
that
now look at everything that you're
creating that you're selling that you're
offering that's in your mind
and they all now kind of make sense
everything that I do
is belief whether it's making videos
like this whether it's
uh making my nft projects with this
going on my Discord whether it's my
other social media content strategies
whether it's speaking whether it's books
whether it's my entrepreneur Heroes
trading cards that we turned
entrepreneurs into into Heroes and made
them made them their own baseball cards
and use that to raise six figures for
Kiva to help entrepreneurs in Africa
build their businesses right whatever
I'm doing it feels like it could be all
over the place but it's not because it's
still belief because at the end of the
day what I want to do is spread belief
Jeff Bezos wants to spread customer
obsession
he wants to he wants to make a better
experience for customers and so he's in
all sorts of different fields
why it feels like it's all over the
place it's not because Amazon is not
just a book business
Amazon is in the customer experience
business
that's his most important core value
what's your most important core value
it'll help make everything make more
sense it'll help make your life make
more sense your business makes more
sense and it'll help your customers
understand better what you're doing I
remember watching a clip of Jay-Z being
interviewed and
they were asking him how do you move
from
making music to being an entrepreneur to
having all these businesses how does
that make sense
and he said it's just an extension of
being creative
see for him it's not just about the
music it's about expressing creativity
and every field can add more creativity
entrepreneurship can be more creative
investing can be more creative product
lines can be more creative he sees
himself not as a musician but as a force
of creativity his most important core
value is creativity so it just makes
sense to him to be able to jump from one
field to another to another to another
where most people are stuck in the craft
right you don't just do one thing you
don't want to do one thing that's why
you're an entrepreneur you don't want to
just do one little narrow thing for the
rest of your life
but it feels like you're all over the
place
and you are until you can wrap it under
your most important core value and what
that does is gives you permission to
explore and to try and to Taste and to
go into new fields
but also
the ability to do something much bigger
because whatever your most important
core value is
that's what you want to spread to the
world
I want to spread more belief to the
world Jay-Z wants to spread more
creativity to the world and he could
have done what most people do
most rappers most musicians stick to
just doing that thing okay well that's
what I love and that's what I know and
so I'm just gonna stick to doing that
how you become Mogul status
right how you start to change the rules
of the game how you start to have a much
wider impact and bigger reach is to
recognize that I don't just do one thing
I don't just have one skill
I've got a message
I've got a core value I want to put out
to the world
and there's multiple ways for me able to
do that
so Jay-Z sees himself through the lens
of creativity and then it makes sense
and it gives himself the permission to
go off and Chase those other ambitions
so for you think about what is that most
important core value and some easy hacks
again both my books go through this in a
lot more detail but think about who your
favorite teacher was growing up think
about who what you loved about your
parents think about your favorite movies
your favorite songs uh think about
anything that made you come alive any
experience why did you love that teacher
for me was my my OAC my grade 12 uh
French teacher why it's not because she
taught me French
your favorite teacher wasn't because
they taught your subject matter because
they made you a better human Madame Farr
at my school she helped me believe in
myself more
when I doubted myself when I wasn't
getting the grades that I wanted to get
she helped turn me from a BNC student to
a straight A Plus student in my last
year
she believed in me and she taught me how
to believe in myself that's why I love
her not because she taught me French
right who was your favorite teacher why
why they made you a better human somehow
what was it about them and when you can
connect the dots and all the things that
make you come alive from your favorite
teacher and favorite books and favorite
music favorite lyrics favorite favorite
TV shows favorite movies favorite
friends right favorite Heroes you can
connect the dots you like them but
instead of it it being a happenstance
like you hope that good things happen to
you you can now design it you can
engineer it
I want to bring more believe into my
life and now that that's on my
Consciousness now that I'm aware of it I
can make that happen as opposed to just
hoping something positive happens to me
when you figure out your one word your
most important core value you can
engineer your life to bring more of that
into you and then the more you have you
can give more you can serve more you can
help more you can uplift up others more
you can motivate and Inspire and give
courage and Hope
to the world more
because you have more to give right
review if you're running on empty you
don't have much to give to anybody
so it starts with that awareness
of what is your single most important
core value
and then bring that to your life
and your business
I believe Bezos is about customer
experience
Jay-Z is about creativity what are you
what are you
what do you value the most
and then with that lens look at your
life
look at your business and see where are
you following through
and crushing it and where are you not
living up to it where are you doing the
wrong things
whatever your life needs a little bit
more of that
because when you can look at your life
through that lens that's your best self
looking back at you
that's the life you want to be living
your highest self looking back at you
and saying hey right here
the reason why you're not happy is
because you're not living your most
important core value
figure that out and you have a road map
you have a guide you have a compass for
the rest of your life self-confidence
comes from doing difficult things
self-confidence self-love self-respect
it all comes from deciding to do
something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people will let you off the hook
the people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
done it you know like that's the worst
feeling in the world that you could have
done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and padding on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry can't see
we had like you see some here behind me
it's like look at see that mountain of
snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rucking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
I there's no path to wacon and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like I could look out the window
and say ah so much snow I'm not gonna do
that I'll do it when there's less snow
you know and then the next day there's
less snow there's still snow in the next
it's still snow and then all of a sudden
you just gave up on the Habit right like
you let yourself off the hook to say
I'll do it tomorrow and then and then
you never do it and then the habit's
gone and that's what you're teaching
yourself this is why it leads to
Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
gonna do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so there's a snow is up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was oh man why
is there no path why is nobody shoveled
this why has nobody still Blowfish like
gotta get over there I got a backpack on
I'm rocking I'm sweating like crazy I'm
already exhausted now I gotta go through
this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so that's
okay go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snoped your
knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you'll look outside
and see the snow and not go just by
default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you're not
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
yeah I'm walking through I'm freezing uh
I'm taking one kind of giant step at a
time snow is getting all through my
boots all down my legs I I almost slip
and fall I have a coffee that I that I
picked up uh it's dripping all over the
place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best let's go
let's go Evan you got this man let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating the path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to service
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships and your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway uh because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step grip by
Brick one snow uh storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
different
in heart the key to enjoying your life
is being present the key to focusing is
being present the key to feeling like
you're valuable and what you do matters
is being present being present is at the
core to a lot of great things but a lot
of people really struggle to stay
present because what are you doing most
people spend most of their time
either thinking about the past
or thinking about the future and not
even in a positive way you spend time
thinking about the past living in regret
of all the things that you could have
done you could have said you should have
done you should have said I wish I did
that I wish that video I made didn't
suck you know I wish I wish I wish I
wish why didn't I and we beat ourselves
up does that sound familiar is that you
maybe even a little a little bit or we
spend our time being anxious about the
future
I think as entrepreneurs we get excited
about the future of where we could go
and what we could build and that's
that's the fun daydreaming part but a
lot of thinking about the future is
stress inducing it's anxiety it's it
worrying about what could go wrong all
the millions of things that could go
wrong that may never go wrong but we're
still worried about them right again
does that sound somewhat familiar when
you are stuck living in the past or
living in the future you're never
obviously present but you're not happy
you're not productive you're not focused
you're not creating you're not serving
none of it and you're not fulfilled
I look at people who want to get started
on YouTube for example or entrepreneurs
are trying to launch their business
and
people made maybe one video or two
videos and because it didn't work out
you made a video and you felt
embarrassed by yourself or you launched
a product and somebody had one bad piece
of feedback you would live in that same
negativity over and over and over and
over and over again
people ask me well what happens when you
have a bad video what happens when your
video bombs I was speaking at Brendan
burchard's influencer Summit yesterday
and
somebody asked me what do you do when a
video doesn't take off or do well
like lots of my videos don't take off
and do well
I know which ones are gonna blow up the
ones that have blown up surprise me like
that's the one that blew up I love this
one so much more
how do I keep going because I'm looking
to the next one like I'm worried I'm
working on videos now I don't know what
I released yesterday the day before the
day before
because I'm making new content
think about how you got over a
relationship well you when you get into
a new relationship it's easy to forget
about your last relationship it's
thinking about what you're doing now
and if you have nothing right now what
do you do if there's nothing to do right
now you spend your time in regret about
the past or worried about the future
it's not enough action happening right
now I don't care about videos that
failed in the past because I'm going to
be making tons more another one comes
out today and another one tomorrow
another one tomorrow and it's it's a
moment to reflect and say hey okay I
could have done better on that one or
why didn't this one do well okay this
moment here that sucked perfect I'm
making one today I'll make it better
at least that's the intent maybe I don't
achieve it but that's the intent and we
show up with that intent every day you
will eventually make it better
most people get too caught up on on the
mistakes that they made in the past it's
in the past
you did the best you could with what
you've got remind yourself of that you
did the best you could
with what you had
great don't be so hard on yourself keep
making
because the worst thing you can do is
quit now the worst thing you do is stop
now because when you look back on your
life when you're 120 that you'll regret
that you you stopped you regret that you
had a chance you had a moment
you could have done something and you
didn't like that's the biggest regret of
all
not taking any kind of action not the
mistakes that you made you we don't
regret really the things that we did
most of the things that people regret
are the things they did not do
most people's biggest regrets are not
taking enough action
letting that little man voice inside
their head
tell them all the reasons why they
weren't going to win
convincing themselves that they weren't
capable
and as a result they stopped when they
wish they had the courage the strength
the tenacity to keep going
right that could be you you could you
could you could get going you keep going
you could stay present you could make
the next thing
and at the same time A lot of people are
then also worried about the future
well what if I make this and it doesn't
work out I thought I was talking to
people again yesterday about their
YouTube channels and the same person
asked me
well what if it
doesn't work out
like what if I make videos and nobody
sees them so what if nobody sees my
videos and then the next question was
what if people see my videos and they
don't like me
so this person at the same time is
afraid of people not seeing their videos
and people seeing their videos
so how does that make any sense right
this is this is the loop that we get
stuck in you're afraid of people not
seeing you and you're afraid of people
seeing you like you can't win the mental
dialogue we have it with ourselves we
can't win
that's not possible
we need to start to flip that we need to
we need to rewire ourselves
and that starts again with being present
like you can't control what the outcome
is going to be in the future but you
can't control what you're doing right
now
if you can switch so that you are mostly
present
not really thinking about the past
unless it's gratitude right if you can
flip the regret of the past to gratitude
right and if you can switch the anxiety
for the future to excitement or vision
that's when you really start to win
somebody came to an event that I did in
Toronto and asked me
these guys drove up from Boston to do a
podcast with me and then stuck around
for my event and they asked me how much
of your time do you spend
percentage-wise
living in the past present future
and I said zero percent passed
85 present
15 future
and the 15 is
is Vision what I want to create you know
as entrepreneurs we have to be a little
bit forward-thinking but it's it's 85
present
I don't even know what day it is
like it's present not even present to
today but present to this moment I don't
know what day it is I don't know what
time it is
I know what I'm doing after this all I
know is I'm here right now with you guys
and that allows for Focus that allows
for happiness that allows for purpose
that allows for life to give you so many
gifts when you're not stuck living in
the past or the future
so how do you do it how do you how do
you get there
I think the best thing you can do
is every time you catch yourself
drifting daydreaming forward or back in
a negative way
you catch it every time you can catch it
you won't catch it most of the time so
don't put this impossibly High burden on
yourself that every time I'm I'm
thinking about the past and I'm living
in regret I'm Gonna Catch and do
something about it you won't catch it
you won't catch it this is this is
Decades of un unwiring our brain right
it's fine don't don't have when you're
starting something new don't have crazy
expectations that you have to get it
perfect or you're a failure
right this is the problem not just with
this one exercise but with everything
don't expect to be great out of the gate
you won't you're just starting you're at
the beginning why do you think you're
going to be fantastic and because the
first time it doesn't work out perfectly
then we quit that is not how it works
right you you need to expect to suck at
the beginning that's okay
that's how you learn something every
time you can catch yourself drifting
you're you're living in a past in regret
or a future being stressed out just try
to bring it back to right now
just bring her back to the present and
focus on anything focus on a physical
object you can you could I could focus
on my coffee like how do I how can you
get present right now you focus on the
coffee wow look at this coffee cup you
know it's tall it's red I'm I'm grateful
for the beverage inside here uh I like
that they have sleep oh it's got a maple
leaf on it right like this is all I'm
being present right now with the cup of
coffee it is warm I can feel the
sensation on my hands
I can taste it in my mouth right
where most of the time even when you're
eating something most of the time when
you're eating something you're usually
focused on something else right you're
eating while you're on your phone you're
eating while you're watching a video
you're eating while you're doing
something else and not ever actually
enjoying the food because we're thinking
about what's next
so every time you can catch it you just
try to bring it back to the moment so
right now
and then what's going to happen is the
more you do that
the more you'll catch it
so right now maybe you're catch it one
percent of the time but the more you do
that and practice that just pick one
thing to focus on that's in your
environment or focus on your breath
right it's why meditation works so well
with a mantra or breath work because it
gives you something to focus on when
you're first starting out with being
present and focused it's helpful to have
somewhere to put your attention because
focus on nothing doesn't feel like very
practical advice to the beginner trying
to figure this out so you focus on your
breath and anytime your mind wanders
bring her back to the breath every time
you get stressed or anxious or worried
or what you're going to do next bring it
back to the breath every time you get
bored
bring her back to the breath right the
breath could be anything the breath
could be the cup of coffee look at the
cup of coffee feel the cup of coffee
every time you get distracted you're
worrying about work or your life back to
the cup of coffee back to your Mantra
right all of that can work it's just
picking something to to ground you back
in being in the present
and again the more you catch it and the
more you do it the more you'll catch the
next one
and then while you're doing again the
next time it's a skill that you learn
you're retraining your brain how to work
and what you'll find is the more you can
do that and the more you practice it
bit by bit
day by day
you'll find yourself
having less stress
being more productive
staying more focused
caring less about what other people
think about you
and overall being happier
and what that does is free you up to
actually go and do the work that's
inside you the genius that you've got
to put up to the world
and serve
being present
is the key to unlocking your happy life
less time living regret about the past
less time living in the stress of the
future and anxiety for what may come
and more time focused on what can you do
right now
today in this moment
to be proud of yourself
and live your best life your energy
changes how you show up when you are
happy positive optimistic full of life
Creative Energy you you make amazing
things
but when you feel negative down
depressed side for yourself low energy
you know you don't make amazing things
and this is not
something new that I'm telling you you
know this the challenges we are not in a
high energy state
consistently enough to stay consistent
on our goals so follow through to create
the momentum because we allow outside
forces as well as our internal voice to
keep us small to keep us protected to
keep us scared to depress our courage
muscle
and then even though you have great
ideas and great Ambitions and a great
heart and a desire to serve it doesn't
happen doesn't happen because
the energy isn't connected to it if
you've got
a big idea
but low energy
nothing happens
you don't follow through and you end up
seeing other people with a worse version
of your idea
but just more energy go off and do it
have you ever seen it happen you ever
seen somebody
make tons of money have a huge impact
off of your idea somebody with less
heart and less vision and less
creativity but they just they just did
it they just got started they just took
action and just stayed consistent in
their energy and they made it happen and
you didn't because you allowed the
energy to dip
and so
If energy is so important then how do we
how do we manage your energy how do we
keep it high and doesn't mean that you
always have to be on top of the world
and you don't have to delude yourself
and say I'm amazing this is going to be
the greatest day of all time like you
don't
doing things that you don't believe
won't help you get the energy that you
need because you'll do those things say
This is BS this isn't working
you don't always have to be in Peak
energy
but what you didn't need to do is being
the right energy to serve your mission
and whatever you're doing today so let
me use me as an example on today
is a great example because I did not
sleep well last night had had two and a
half hours sleep just tossing and
turning and
just could not could not get to sleep so
I slept from like 6 30 to 9 o'clock did
not sleep until 6 30 in the morning and
that is thankfully a rare occurrence you
know most nights I get eight hours sleep
seven and a half to eight and a half
hours sleep
but
on a day like today when I woke up and
did not have a ton of energy I did not
wake up and say yes I feel like crushing
it let's go and
I didn't want to do something I would
feel fake and disingenuous because if
you don't believe it then it's not going
to happen anyway
so what did I do well
first off videos have to happen today
because that's part of my identity right
so momentum has to happen so if you
start to train yourself when you create
a calendar and say okay today is a blank
I'm filming this on a Tuesday today's a
Tuesday Tuesday's my video day no matter
what I'm filming videos I gotta film
videos it's got to happen it may not be
my best video
but I'm going to show up and give it my
the best that I've got the best energy
this is this is a lot lower energy than
I would normally show up with a video
but it's a different vibe it's a
different kind of energy and hopefully
it still serves and maybe maybe you like
and connect more with this energy then
I've been yelling in the car I don't
know but videos have to happen first off
second get outside you know get outside
get fresh air get some sun on my face if
you you know you want to change your
energy you want to shift where you're at
and how you're thinking because it's
part physical energy but also just
mental energy how do you feel about what
you're doing and what's going to happen
today and getting out of your home
changing your physical environment and
getting some sun on your face
can make a huge difference so every
morning I have my believe walk and I'm
walking around the park getting some
green getting some sun hopefully it's
not raining today's a beautiful day and
everybody it starts to make you feel a
little bit happier
a little bit more in the right energy
space
music is a great way to change your
energy and often what we do is we put on
songs that make us feel how we currently
are so if you feel sad you put on a sad
song If you feel low you put on a low
song and you feel chill you put on a
Chill song
where what we want to do is if you want
to change your energy put on the song
that matches that energy
if you want to feel happier upbeat put
unhappy or beat songs I have a playlist
on my channel called hashtag believe all
caps on the on the letters believe
that's all the songs that I listen to
and every day I've got that playlist
going I pick a random song and it just
starts playing and they're all songs
that if they came on it would make me
move
and when you move you start to change
your energy
what I'm trying to do is again not
create some fake energy but something I
can actually connect with I'm putting on
songs that I actually like I actually
like having some sunshine on my face you
know I actually like doing the work that
I'm about to do
but it requires you showing up with a
certain level of energy
and then the last one is
you know who you're feeding your mind
with who are you around who you're
surrounded by both the people in your
life you know actual humans
and the videos that you watch or books
that you read and podcasts you consume I
remember on the weekend
you gotta guard against this it's crazy
so on the weekend I went to go
meets an old family friend
and
he just had
a lot of limiting
beliefs about him and what he's creating
and where he wants to go and it wasn't
it wasn't meant to be a coaching session
I'm not there to help him but just a
really negative low energy on a weekend
and I'm you know that's not usually part
of my routine on the weekend and so I go
to meet him
and my whole day ended up being thrown
off until I caught it at night to say
why why am I so low and negative today
in comparison to what I would normally
be and I thought back like oh yeah you
know what ever since I went to see him I
was fine in the morning I went to see
him and had this negative ripple effect
you know like you could have a positive
ripple effect on people you watch a
video and it can have a positive ripple
effect on you but but there's negative
equal effects too
and the people who you're surrounded by
who you're hanging out with or you're
watching on YouTube or podcasts Etc they
can have a negative ripple effect on you
as well
and so he had this
negative ripple effect on me that lasted
almost the whole day until I caught it
in the evening said this isn't what I
want
it's not even my voice it's like his
voice planted in me why am I feeling
this way thinking this way I don't like
it
and so it became a conscious choice and
I applied a lot of the same things I got
it I went outside went outside reset get
some fresh air it always helps me put on
some music songs that I actually like
not some fake song that somebody else
likes and says dance to this it'll make
you feel good songs that I actually like
there are some songs that if it came on
it would
make you move it doesn't mean you get up
and dance and go [ __ ] and crazy but
there's some songs that if it came on
you would Bob your head or you would tap
your feet or bounce your knee there's
some songs that just make you do that
right so put on one of those songs it
would naturally make you feel happier
so I did that too and then in terms of
just guarding against people I made a
note that hey the next time I go see
this person he's a he's a family friend
so the next time I go see him
uh which is not often but still the next
time I see him I need to remind myself
of this
you know that that I need to I need to
have my shield ready
I need to give love as much as possible
and I'm not going to allow his
negativity to to break my shield you
know to permeate through
and so the more that you can catch those
things
the more you'll stay in a more energetic
state
and all of this again is not trying to
force fake energy and have you feel like
you're doing something unnatural I think
it's actually the most natural thing of
all time I think getting sun is natural
I think smiling and being optimistic is
natural I think everything I think the
negativity inside your head was planted
there was put there by other people
that's what's unnatural when you were a
kid and smiling and happy had dreams for
the future everything was possible
everything was hopeful
sure we had bad days but you were a
happy kid
and all of those dreams and positivity
get squashed out of us by other people
who hate their lives and so I think
having energy is actually the most
natural thing not every day has to be on
top of the world but
having positive energy is natural having
Sunshine leading to happiness is natural
putting on music and and dancing and
moving is natural
being around other positive optimistic
happy people when you're around them
you'll naturally be more positive
optimistic and happy and so it's about
finding what is a natural flow for you
that when you do these things
it brings out a better energy in you
it brings out a happier more positive
more optimistic you and if you know what
some of those things are
you can copy my list if you want some of
them right sunshine music videos
then put into your daily routine
put into your daily calendar every day
this has to happen
because if you did the thing just
imagine this you've had days when you
felt energetic and you've had days when
you didn't and every would everybody
would give you the the out right like a
day like today two and a half hours
sleep
everybody would give me the hours like
it's okay you don't have to do it
there are days when you need to bring
the energy
if you did that every day
just imagine for the next month every
day you did the thing that puts you in a
better energy state
ment that you're on top of the world and
the fake high every day but a better
energy state
you did the thing in the morning that
put you in a better energy State for the
next 30 days how much does your life
change
how much is how you show up change how
much is the work that you do change how
much does your bank account change how
much is the impact you're creating
change how much of a better father or
mother or husband or wife are you
because you're showing up with more
energy more positive energy
[Music]
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there humans are built to serve you want
to help people it's hardwired into US
serving other people touches the same
part of our brain as eating food and
having sex you need it